de commencer puis en espérant que
que mes traditions pour nous nous
rejoindre ultérieurement si rencontrer
des problèmes de de connexion ce qui ce
qui est possible donc cadre de son étude
sur le frontière agricole dans les
outre-mer dans les deux rapporteurs sont
vivaient Lopez et dit la délégation
sénatoriale aux outre-mer 27 cet
après-midi un focus sur les aspects
notariaux et juridiques de cette
question ce focus va se dérouler en deux
temps nous allons tout d'abord entendre
des représentants des chambres des
notaires qui pourront nous apporter
évidemment leur expertise et leur
témoignages de praticiens dans un second
temps vers 17h nous accueillerons des
avocats du CNB qui ont bien également
voulu répondre à notre invitation afin
de partager leur expérience de terrain
pour la première séquence je vous
remercie de leur participation en
visioconférence maître Sylvie pense
cervelle notaire à Saint-Denis de la
Réunion bonjour madame présidente de la
Chambre inter départementale des
notaires de la Réunion et Mayotte maître
Éric Hoarau notaire à Saint-Louis de la
Réunion
et puis devrait je l'espère nous
rejoindre mettre Emmanuel du surveiller
notaire au Lamentin en Martinique
mesdames messieurs
[Musique]
pour assister à la réunion avec grand
plaisir merci pour la précision mesdames
messieurs vous allez avoir la parole
pour votre propos liminaire afin de vous
permettre de présenter vos observations
avant les échanges avec nos collègues un
stage je vais donner la parole à nos
rapporteurs donc Tani Mohamed solidy qui
a une contrainte de timing et vivait
Lopez également si elle le souhaite dans
la foulée de tany donc on inverse un
petit peu l'ordre d'intervention puis
après je vous donnerai la parole dans
l'ordre que j'ai évoqué pour que vous
puissiez traverser un peu de manière
transversale les questions qui vous ont
été adressées comme une trame à cette
audition
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs chers collègues
bonjour cher Maître merci d'avoir
répondu comme d'habitude à cette à cette
sollicitation qui est très importante
dans le cadre de cette étude sur le
foncier agricole
dans nos autres mères au moment où
l'autonomie alimentaire ou en tout cas
la nécessité de produire plus localement
se fait sentir au lendemain de la crise
de covid et
durant la crise de de l'Ukraine qui
démontre à quel point importer de loin
dans nos outre-mer et pénalisant notre
étude va porter sur
la raification des terres agricoles au
moment où cette nécessité de produire
davantage dans nos outre-mer se fait
se fait jour et il est très important de
vous entendre madame monsieur les
notaires parce que nous avons commencé
nos auditions et des aspects juridiques
se font se font jour nous nous sommes
déplacés récemment en Martinique et
nous entendons des préconisations nous
entendons des demandes des doléances
mais est-ce que juridiquement
c'est c'est ces propositions ces
propositions sont tenables et notamment
il y a une problématique d'installation
des jeunes et en même temps excusez-moi
de parler comme ça des jeunes
agriculteurs et en même temps les les
plus
âgés rechignent même en étant à la
retraite à laisser la place tout
simplement parce que le
[Musique]
de retraite n'est pas suffisante et le
fond qu'ils ont je parle de fond en
faisant référence au fond au fond de
commerce et bien n'est pas suffisamment
valorisé et ce qui fait que il y a une
réelle difficulté de transmission et
avant la transmission de valorisation de
ce fond et à votre connaissance cher
Maître est-ce que
il existe un équivalent du fonds de
commerce en matière agricole et comment
pourrait-il être le cas échéant
valoriser et transmis notamment aux
jeunes générations d'agriculteurs
vous le savez je sais que Sylvie pense à
énormément suivi les précédents travaux
sur le foncier tout court et notamment
la mise en place d'outils tels que la
Commission de l'urgence foncière à
Mayotte mais aussi la mise en pratique
de la loi les chimies sur les sorties
d'indivision qu'est-ce que l'on pourrait
dire à quelques années de du début de
ces de
ces institutions et de et de ses de ses
lois
on le sait la cuve doit laisser la place
à Mayotte à un GIP et est-ce que d'ores
et déjà mettre pause vous qui suivez
considérablement ces sujets à Mayotte
aujourd'hui on peut faire un point et
aussi par rapport à la loi les chimie
j'ai vu que le compte-rendu des travaux
que nous avions mené avec le Conseil
supérieur du notariat le 10 janvier
dernier
sont son produit est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en parler si tenter que ces travaux
pourraient concerner l'aspect Fossier
l'aspect agricole du foncier voilà
les quelques observations que je voulais
vous vous formuler les quelques
questions que je sur lesquelles je
voulais insister en plus des selles qui
ont été transmises et je regrette
beaucoup de ne pas être avec vous
jusqu'au bout de de cet entretien mais
je suis vrai avec intérêt le replay
comme on dit un bon français encore
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à cette
invitation
avec plaisir donc
oui alors le problème le problème est
différent si on se si on pose la
problématique sur l'île de la Réunion ou
sur l'île de bayotte
puisqu'effectivement à maillon nous
avons une cuve qui va effectivement se
transformer en GIP et quel était le but
de cette de cette culte ou de ce GIP
c'est le problème de l'occupant qui est
sur des terres qui peut éventuellement
cultiver des terres et qui n'a pas de
reconnaissance en termes de titres il ne
peut pas transmettre il ne peut pas
avoir d'héritiers puisque il n'est pas
titré donc on est sur une sur une
problématique en fait tout simplement
humaine ou vous avez des terrains
considérés comme étant agricoles et qui
du fait de d'installation de personnes
enfants depuis des années exploitant
souvent d'ailleurs les terrains comme à
la Réunion il y a beaucoup d'exploitants
qui n'ont pas été titrés ou qui
souhaitent être titrés par les
propriétaires dit colons et ils ont
toute cette reconnaissance là pour être
titrée mais c'est extrêmement compliqué
pour eux effectivement de pouvoir avoir
une division du terrain et de pouvoir au
moins avoir la reconnaissance de la
construction qu'ils ont bâti depuis des
années voilà un petit peu les remontées
que l'on a à nous sur les problématiques
agricoles je pense que mettre Éric
Poirot va compléter ce que je ce que je
vais dire mais le souci est un souci
humain c'est un problème de
reconnaissance et effectivement d'un
côté nous avons la prior donner
priorités à aux terres agricoles et au
fait que c'est un agricole doivent
continuer à exister elles doivent pas
être morcelées elles doivent être elles
doivent appartenir à des femme qui
exploite sinon bien évidemment elle
perdent le caractère agricole et elle se
sont des terrains qui deviennent en
friche et de l'autre côté nous avons
cette particularité d'avoir des
personnes qui sont là depuis des
décennies et qui pour elle se sont leurs
terres et ils ne vivent pas devenir à la
fin elle ne peut pas être propriétaire
donc là on a une vraie problématique
est-ce que
est-ce que tu veux rajouter quelque
chose
je peux le rajouter au niveau de notre
île notamment au niveau de ma fate et
des terres des hauts où on a beaucoup
d'agriculteurs qui est beaucoup de
personnes qui occupent du terrain depuis
plusieurs années et qui ne sont pas
titrés aujourd'hui ces terrains sont
protégés par l'Espace Naturel Sensible
par la
le règlement d'urbanisme de
je crois que c'est le Scott de Lille qui
empêche qui empêche
de toucher à ces terrains par le biais
de la protection de l'ONF on a
donc impossibilité de faire reconnaître
un droit quelconque à une des personnes
si ce n'est que par des conventions
d'occupation précaires dans ce
territoire des Hauts de l'île
donc pour les motifs qui qui empêche la
transmission de terrain qui empêche la
transmission de l'exploitation et qui
empêche tout simplement de pouvoir
augmenter ses exploitations et préserver
cette exploitation tout simplement
oui bonjour maître donc j'ai une petite
question justement sur ça donc si je
comprends bien la protection des espaces
naturels prévôt sur celles des terres
agricoles et le retour à l'agriculture
de terre en friche et rare et difficile
c'est ce que d'ailleurs nous avions cru
comprendre en Martinique puisqu'ils
envisagaient plutôt de demander à des
grosses exploitations de céder une
partie de leur terre pour installer de
jeunes agriculteurs plutôt que de
remettre à l'agriculture des terrains
riches comment comment c'est possible ça
il était en friche on préfère les
laisser en friche plutôt que de les
mettre en agriculture et prendre des
terres qui sont déjà cultivées de
grossesse
ça augmente pas ça augmente pas les
terres agricoles puisqu'elles sont déjà
cultivées c'était en fait si vous avez
une grosse exploitation qui est tout
entretenu bon ben c'est d'interagricole
alors que les terrains frites devraient
être devraient pouvoir augmenter puisque
on a cru comprendre qu'ils avaient 12000
hectares de terrain friche et que pour
pouvoir avoir l'autonomie alimentaire
2000 hectares de ces friches seraient
largement suffisante donc est-ce que les
friches prévalent sur les terres
agricoles
merci
alors
je suis désolé je vous ai rejoint en
retard et je n'avais pas été agréé donc
ça s'est bien passé j'ai pu vous
rejoindre et je suis désolé pour ce
retard donc j'ai je vais puis que vous
avez parlé de la Martinique après mes
confrères de la Guadeloupe de la Réunion
pardon et de Mayotte je peux juste
témoigner effectivement qu'on nous avons
souvent des exploitations agricoles des
grandes exploitations agricoles ou des
moyennes exploitations qui fonctionnent
bien et nous avons beaucoup de friches
ou de terrain qui ont été non seulement
placé en naturel et plus en agricole
donc je pense que par rapport à une
situation je suis pas très fort en
histoire mais je pense qu'il y a pas
portail il y a 100 ans les zones
agricoles en diminué profit de zones
naturelles qui n'étaient plus exploitées
et au-delà de ça dans les zones AG il y
a beaucoup de friches la SAFER tous ces
organismes là en des états des lieux et
aller comme disait madame la signatrice
je crois que qui venait d'intervenir
au lieu d'aller prendre des fleurs sur
des exploitations qui fonctionnent bien
effectivement il y a la question de
simplement l'utilisation des friches et
aussi je signale à nos à nos à tous des
gens qui nous écoutent dans dans ce dans
cette discussion c'est que pour avoir ce
piéger à la CPAS à la commission
territoriale d'aménagement foncier etc
on s'apercevait qu'il y avait beaucoup
d'états de boisement
qui empêchaient à des agriculteurs de de
pouvoir déboiser et de réinvestir des
morceaux de terre qu'ils avaient occupés
il y a 30 40 ou 50 ans qu'ils avaient vu
eux-mêmes
exploité et il pouvait plus parce qu'il
y a un état de poison qui est constaté
de manière très dans le Code rural pour
la partie de nos départements et
territoires et c'était un frein à la
remise en exploitation ce qui me ce qui
me paraissait assez surprenant mais
encore une fois je suis pas un
spécialiste mais comme l'occasion de
parler mais m'a été donnée je vous
l'intervenir voilà je vous remercie de
votre attention
ok alors ce que je vous propose pour le
déroulé pour reprendre le fil normal de
notre audition
habituelle je vous propose de donner la
parole successivement à mettre Sylvie
pense cervelle maître Hoarau et maître
du survillier au regard du questionnaire
qu'on vous a envoyé et qui sert de trame
donc on va pas le faire de manière entre
guillemets scolaire je vous invite
simplement à aller au travers du
questionnaire sur les points qui vous
paraissent être Saillon et bien
évidemment comme à son habitude la
délégation est preneuse de support écrit
ou de notes sur le sujet du front
agricole que vous souhaiteriez nous
faire part évidemment notamment les
réponses écrites si jamais vous
n'évoquez pas tous les éléments au
travers de audition est-ce que se
dérouler vous convient
je vous laisse la parole et puis à la
suite de vos interventions je donnerai
la parole à la rapporteur puisque
l'autre rapporteur a dû nous abstenter
puis enfin les questions pour les
parlementaires qui sont présents dans
cette audition je vous remercie beaucoup
je crois que c'est vous madame dans
l'ordre dans l'ordre que j'ai donné donc
Madame maître oui voilà de ce sera
beaucoup plus simple
[Musique]
plus particulièrement de la Réunion donc
tout à l'heure effectivement on est
évoqué la commission d'urgence foncière
donc la commission d'urgence foncière
donc le GP a pour mission de pouvoir
justement
filtrer à toutes les personnes qui sont
occupantes quel que soit le terrain qui
qui est concerné que ce soit du terrain
agricole ou pas de pouvoir titrer des
personnes qui donc
reconnaissent donc leur
occupation au terme de documents qui
font que à un moment donné elles vont
pouvoir bénéficier de la prescription 39
on est aujourd'hui sur Mayotte dans des
problématiques de de
[Musique]
le cas des transactions qui se font
entre maori donc on est sur une
véritable problème de transmission du
patrimoine qui s'oppose en fait avec la
valorisation de des cases agricoles
voilà c'est assez compliqué parce que
d'un côté effectivement il faut défendre
et développer la terre
l'intera agricole au niveau de Mayotte
ou au niveau de la Réunion et de l'autre
côté cela vient toucher profondément les
personnes qui sont propriétaires parce
que elles ne peuvent plus derrière
transmettre librement ou diviser ou
partager au niveau de des enfants donc
c'est c'est un vrai problème de
transmission en tout cas au niveau de
Mayotte et de et de la Réunion
Eric je te laisse la parole oui très
bien alors
au niveau de la problématique du foncier
agricole
je voulais je voulais vous dire qu'il y
avait plusieurs échelles au niveau de
cette problématique
plusieurs intérêts se poser bien
évidemment donc on a la
la problématique d'une politique
publique finalement puisque au niveau de
de ma fate comme je vous l'indiquais
est-ce que les espaces naturels
prévalaient ou pas oui c'est dans
l'ordre de des règles juridiques c'est
ce qui
c'est d'abord désigner le caractère de
protection à cet été agricole et cela va
nous empêcher de de faire quoi que ce
soit on est allé à la rencontre des
habitants sur sur ma fate
on n'a pas de d'outils juridique en tant
qu'en qualité de notaire au niveau de
notre aspect notariale pour pouvoir
transmettre les terres
les terres entre agriculteurs même ou
entre privés
à ce niveau là donc les terres sont
totalement protégées par le biais des
régions magnétiques tout ça dépend de la
politique publique à adapter dans dans
ces terres mais ça ça date de salade de
2020 si je me trompe pas descendre 2020
plus aucune utilisation de cette aire
n'est possible dans les hauts de l'île
de la Réunion
intérêt prix intérêt public qu'il faut
faire mettre face à l'intérêt privé de
transmission comme disait maître ponce
encore une fois je me focalise sur notre
aspect notarial au sein de nos études
aujourd'hui les agriculteurs ont
enregistré le les agriculteurs et les
personnes
les clients en général ont enregistré
qu'ils ne pouvaient plus partager les
théories
à tort puisque la règle aujourd'hui au
niveau de la protection de cet air on
est sur un contrôle de morcellement des
terres donc si des personnes viennent
vous voir pour partager un terrain
il y a le contrôle de morcellement qui
entre en jeu avec la cdp-9 et la et la
CDF
et cette prophétie cette procédure peut
sert à protéger
les terres agricoles mais elle peut dans
certains cas dans certaines situations
freiner leur développement
il y a aussi droit de prendre soin de la
SAFER qui
qui sert à cette protection des
terribles et
on peut observer au sein de de nos
études certains pratiques qui peuvent
être amenées à on peut le ressentir à ce
que les gens vont essayer de contourner
ses droits de préemption et donc on est
là pour veiller à
faire en sorte que par le biais d'un de
de
stratagèmes juridique qui naissait pas
de contourner ce droit de préemption que
les affaires et puis mettre en place
c'est un intérêts privés publics font
face à nos problématiques de terrain
niveau notamment de les propos
préliminaires de
sénateurs avec qui avait indiqué sur la
loi sur la loi de chimie ou sur les
titres de propriété on a un problème
récurrent d'absence de sites de
propriété et de gens qui essayent de
faire des prescriptions 30 air
avec une multiplication
des indivisions qui passent avec les
temps
et un cadastre parfois qui n'est pas à
jour donc cette problématique là
sur l'absence de site de propriété il y
avait une loi en 2018 qui nous
permettait de valider des prescriptions
trentenaires au bout de 5 ans qui
n'était qui ne serait plus contestable
au bout de 5 ans mais c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui
l'État n'a pas n'a pas
n'a pas soutenu la protection de de ces
actes là puisque beaucoup de notaires
refusent encore de le faire et ça c'est
une vraie problématique à mettre en
place que fait-on quand une personne n'a
pas de type de propriété quand le
terrain ne n'est pas n'est pas titré
quand on ne retrouve aucune aucun
élément au niveau foncier
il faut bien trouver une solution assez
personne là qui exploite les terrains
qui les habitent
et qui n'ont pas de site de propriété
donc et bien évidemment je parle de
prescription accessive là mais on va
bien mettre le le
les éléments en exergue on n'a pas le
droit aujourd'hui de prescrire un
terrain agricole puisque pour que la
prescription accessible puisse entrer en
jeu il faut l'avoir habiter de manière
mon équivoque sur 30 ans et ce n'est pas
le cas pour une terre agricole qui n'est
pas bâti
donc mais c'est des pistes c'est une
piste de réflexion que je pose là pour
savoir s'il y a pas une possibilité de
valider certaines propriétés
par cet outil
et mon réflexion avoir éventuellement
il y avait une question dans qui
indiquait comme comment résorber le
désordre foncier mais c'est ce que je
répondais dans le formulaire c'est un
certain agriculteurs exploitent depuis
parfois plus de 30 ans sans aucun bail
ni titre et les recherches foncières ne
permettent pas de déterminer un
propriétaire et une politique de
titrement serait donc
souhaité pour établir un ordre foncier
de ce cadre là
puisque aujourd'hui ça fait vraiment de
ma part je je ne sais pas si mettre si
viponce peut confirmer ses propos mais
la loi l'alchimie
n'a pas n'a pas beaucoup abouti et il y
a encore beaucoup de freins à son
utilisation mais je crois que des
travaux sont menés là-dessus
pour pour y aboutir
avec des propositions de loi ont été qui
ont été proposés donc on permet
justement une utilisation plus simple en
termes de Procédure au niveau de cette
vallée de chimie
ok voilà pour les
tu veux
parler de la loi la chimie est-ce que
selon vous il faudrait la modifier pour
renforcer son application et
son efficacité et quelle amélioration je
vous
les améliorations ont été posées il
s'agit de de
plusieurs points qui ont été proposés
qui sont souvent des blocages au niveau
de la loi des chimie et on a proposé par
le biais du CSN des modifications avec
une table de travail ou avec les
notaires de l'outre-mer ainsi que des
universitaires et représentants du
Tridon qui ont proposé des modifications
de la loi
juste
[Musique]
mais le problème de l'application d'une
loi ce n'est pas un sujet ce n'est pas
un point qui peut bloquer mais plusieurs
points ce n'est pas au niveau fiscal que
ça bloque c'est au niveau ne serait-ce
que de la procédure mais il faut
attendre que le défunt sur les sites de
10 ans donc disons NON 10 ans il y a
déjà pas mal de soucis au niveau de des
sorties d'indivision ensuite vous avez
la problématique de la procédure en
elle-même au niveau des notifications
c'est extrêmement lourd puisque on
devait notifié non seulement aux
personnes qui étaient
opposante mais également à tous les
autres
ou un diviseur et donc on a proposé
effectivement des modifications pour
alléger ces procédures donc on est sur
différents points d'allègement de la
procédure
oui si vous permettez la pension
fiscal comme le dit mon confrères a été
[Musique]
nausée bénéficiaires puisque vraiment la
palette chimie dans la proposition de
loi il était
demandé l'exonération des deux et demi
de partage donc effectivement nous avons
une fiscalité qui est allégée qui est
pour 10 ans et comme le rappeler maître
civil ponce il y a d'une série de
préconisations qui ont été faites suite
au colloque du 10 janvier 2023 sous
l'égide du CSN avec Monsieur sénateur et
le ministre karenko etc et avec un suivi
de ce colloque qui a été établi toujours
sous l'égide du CSN avec les intervalles
les différents intervenants avec une
tentative d'amélioration de tous les
points de blocage que que listés mettre
conservell à savoir la la procédure
elle-même etc et pour répondre à la
question qui a été posée précisément
nous avons demandé un cantonnement je ne
sais pas s'il a été retenu et présenté
au ministre il me semble que non et
c'est ça serait fort dommage parce que
ce cantonnement nous permettrait de
réaliser des partages mais pour
continuer dans la discussion de plus
facilement je veux dire parce qu'on a on
a un vrai problème d'impéconiosité et de
d'équilibre dans les partages avec une
volonté des de certains membres de la
famille d'abandonner si vous voulez leur
part et vous savez bien que sur le plan
fiscal une abandon de droit c'est une
donation pour revenir à pour continuer
sur sur ce qui nous intéresse concernant
la Martinique j'ai l'impression qu'il y
a aussi un système de bail de mise à
bail automatique forcée à un
propriétaire qui ne libérerait pas son
terrain de manière spontanée et
conventionnelle
donc tous ces terrains en friche il y a
eu tout un travail de d'identification
des terrains riches et donc je pense que
la il y a peut-être une volonté
politique et qui a été mise en oeuvre
mais qui n'a pas encore abouti pour
obliger les propriétaires de terrain
libre et non occupés vacances comme on
les appelle pour une mise à veille
forcée à ma connaissance je n'ai pas
entendu dire que des été mis en location
à bail agricole de manière forcée
puisque souvent quand ils étaient
sollicités les propriétaires préférés
signer une convention mais là je sais
que la SAFER de la Martinique pourrait
être interrogée parce qu'ils sont assez
avancés sur sur le sujet et dans le
cadre de notre
général de notre de nos difficultés pour
la résolution des des successions et le
titrement donc ça englobe résolution de
succession ancien petite remontes de
gens qui sont sans titre ou alors avec
des titres tellement oubliés et anciens
parce que les le rythme des successions
n'a pas été n'a pas été réglé tous ces
travaux qui devraient être réalisés pour
avoir une situation plus assainie
situation que peut
en partie résoudre la loi chimie mais
pourra être aussi y compris pour
l'application de la loi la chimie être
mise en oeuvre grâce au GIP qui est en
cours d'établissement à la Martinique
ce GIP qui pourra aider les notaires et
les professionnels dans des travaux qui
sont
insurmontables pour eux mais plus encore
pour les nos concitoyens qui n'arrivent
pas pour des raisons d'impé cognosité de
d'accès aux droits ou
à régler et à réunir les pièces qui sont
nécessaires pour faire une succession
voilà on nous avons beaucoup d'espoir
dans ce GIP titrement Martinique je
crois que le JP fonctionne à Mayotte
sous d'autres appellations donc nous
avons beaucoup d'espoir dans ces dans la
résolution sur les 10 ans ou 15 ans qui
viennent de
ces anciennes successions mais ce n'est
qu'un aspect du problème puisque vous
l'avez dit il y a beaucoup de il y a
beaucoup de terres en friche qui qui ont
peut-être un type de propriété dont les
dans les dans les propriétaires ont un
titre actif et récent et ou encore il y
a des terres en friche qui pourrait être
mise en bye forcée en dehors de tout
rétablissement de du droit propriété par
ailleurs voilà
est-ce que ce que vous pouvez repréciser
les types de contournement du doigt la
préemption de la SAFER
et sont les types de contournement
puisque vous avez le droit de prendre
conscience
donc à deux ventes donc effectivement
c'est où nous avons deux gros contrôles
on peut dire enfin si je peux
au contrôle on a un contrôle sur les
terres qui sont agricoles on a un
contrôle qui se fait lors des ventes et
là ça sert intervient effectivement
et nous avons un contrôle lors des
divisions et là c'est la la
commission départementale ou territorial
d'aménagement foncier là elle a
peut-être d'autres noms j'ai entendu les
noms qui étaient évoqués et qui contrôle
elle le morcellement agricole mais là ça
fait les contournements de la SAFER ça
n'est pas l'usage en fait en réalité les
contournements il y a pas de
contournement quand on utilise des
droits légaux c'est-à-dire que les
ventes entre parents etc sont le droit
de prévention de la SAFER peut-être
primée par des droits qui sont
supérieurs
joue son rôle mais parfois elle joue un
rôle aussi alors c'est le
professionnelle qui parle sans vouloir
c'est un constat sur des
elle intervient lors de vente de terrain
qui font l'origine agricole mais qui ne
sont plus du tout en utiliser de manière
agricole parce qu'ils ont été bâtis etc
et parfois on essaye de on la met un peu
en avant
j'allais dire la pauvre alors que c'est
pas son rôle pour bloquer une
transaction sur un tout petit terrain
qui est déjà bâti depuis des
dizaines d'années donc si vous voulez
après le contournement moi
personnellement je ne le connais pas
puisque toute vent doit être présentée
toute vente qui est éligible au droit de
transition doit être présenté à la SAFER
donc peut-être je laisse mes confrères
en parler
au niveau du compte environnement que
j'ai que j'ai évoqué vous avez certains
certaines personnes qui vont mettre à
bail le terrain pendant trois ans
by enregistré auprès d'une de la de la
Chambre d'Agriculture et
vous
ce bail avec l'autorisation d'exploiter
allouer au profit de de du preneur en
place va exonérer doit prendre
c'est c'est un incontournement qu'on
peut qu'on peut qui peut les gens vont
chercher à être exonérés ce droit de
prévention
je me permets de rajouter effectivement
effectivement vous avez encore un droit
légal d'exemption du droit de pension et
là ça faire contrôle chez nous en tout
cas la réalité de l'exploitation mais si
il n'y a pas de contrôle de cette
réalité d'exploitation pendant 3 ans et
que ou qu'il n'y a pas d'exploitation
réellement effectivement là on en
revient incontournement de la loi mais
il reste quand même assez cantonné et
pour nous s'il n'y a pas de réalité de
l'exploitation ça ça ne passe pas
oui on va on va revenir il y a des
collègues sénateurs qui veulent revenir
sur la division donc Victoria nurel et
puis victoire jasmin dans la foulée Vito
victoire peut-être avant parce que
victoire avait la main et puis avant
ensuite Victoria
oui bonsoir à tous merci monsieur le
Président je voudrais savoir dans la
lignée de ce qui vient d'être dit
concernant les terres inculte concernant
les terrains inculte est-ce que vous
avez des cas où justement on a fait des
récupérations pour permettre à des
jeunes agriculteurs de pouvoir
travailler et quels sont les éventuels
freins qu'il y aurait ça c'est la
première question la deuxième question
c'est aussi par rapport au plan locaux
urbanisme donc très souvent il y a des
réserves foncières qui sont
mis en évidence dans les écrits mais qui
ne sont pas réels je dirais dans la
mesure où quelquefois parce que là il y
a beaucoup de personnes qui font des
recours parce que certaines termes qui
sont agricoles ne le sont pas tout
simplement parce qu'il y a un équilibre
à faire au niveau foncier et on ne tient
pas vraiment compte de la réalité et il
y a beaucoup de de procès et de
personnes qui ne sont pas satisfaites
alors est-ce que vous avez des cas de ce
type et quels sont les freins et les
leviers possible merci
alors si j'ai bien compris vous parliez
au niveau de c'est en cas de préemption
vous parliez c'est ça de au niveau des
réserves foncières parce que il y a les
deux parce que bon il y a pour les
inculte qui ne sont pas utilisés les
terres agricoles qui sont pas utilisés
et pour lesquelles il faudrait peut-être
trouver des solutions comprennent qu'on
parle de foncier agricole donc là il y a
cela et il y a effectivement pour le
prévention également
je n'ai pas de je n'ai pas de recul
là-dessus parce que je n'ai pas ces
cas-là mais au niveau des des préhions
effectivement donc il y a des préhions
alors je sais notamment à Mayotte que
les femmes fait beaucoup de préemption
pour derrière replacer des des
agriculteurs au niveau des terrains
[Musique]
il y a très peu en fait de terrain
véritablement exploités à Mayotte un des
grands il y a pas beaucoup de d'hectares
qui représentent des exploitations c'est
relativement rares donc le on est
quelque part sur une
renouvellement de ces de ces terres à
exploiter à Mayotte et donc la les
femmes qui est relativement récente
finalement dans le temps
s'emploie aujourd'hui à récupérer ces
terres maintenant est-ce que
véritablement il y a déjà des des
exploitations qui sont qui sont
existantes et qui
réussissent à avoir une véritable un
véritable rendement je ne sais pas ça
effectivement ce sont des questions
qu'il faudra poser directement à notre
femme
Victorin Lurel voulait intervenir
en appuyant sur le micro si c'est
possible j'ai fait une recherche en même
temps le Président
je reviens sur l'application de la loi
l'intimides j'ai entendu un certain
nombre de réponses qui sont claires
notamment sur le droit de partage qui
existe et qui figure sur le 750 sur la
demande pour le mécanisme de
cantonnement mais sur la vente elle-même
sur la vente la loi les timide
un visage la vente ou autorise la vente
à raison à la majorité de 50, je crois
1%
50,1%
sur ce sera toujours atteint il me
semble en présence d'un conjoint
successible comme eux des locaux
en pleine propriété
conformément l'article 767 du Code civil
ce conjoint pourra donc à lui seul
imposer la vente du ou des biens aux
autres héritiers
les héritiers qui ne sont pas à
l'initiative de la vente et qui
souhaitent acheter le bien et divi ne
bénéficie pas pour autant d'une priorité
faute de droit de préemption alors même
que le mécanisme de droit de préemption
est protecteur des droits des indivisés
et permettra ainsi d'atténuer les
risques spéculation pour éviter ce
risque je vous pose la question
est-il prévu
peut-on éviter ce risque en prévoyant un
droit de préemption et de substitution
au profit des co-indivisaires je n'ai
pas la réponse et je crois que votre
expertise pourra m'éclairer
est-ce que est-ce qu'un confrère veut
répondre sinon je peux dire un mot
sénateur l'URL c'est très c'est très
intéressant effectivement vous avez
raison dans le cas de deux époux qui
auraient
acheté en communauté donc c'est vraiment
un cas et une succession qui s'ouvre et
ça serait le conjoint
survivant qui aurait la moitié déjà du
bien plus son supplément dans la
succession qui aurait plus de la
majorité je pense de manière tout à fait
objective pour vous répondre que la loi
estimée vise plutôt des successions qui
sont plus anciennes et pas simplement
des successions très suite au décès d'un
premier époux et on est plutôt sur des
indivisions entre les héritiers
eux-mêmes à la première
à la deuxième génération plutôt il me
semble d'ailleurs la loi visée
succession déjà ouverte depuis plus de
10 ans on a parlé de la réduire un peu à
l'ouverture de la succession après cinq
ans
suite au décès mais on est toujours
resté je crois sur les 10 ans
il me semble que
c'est le cas visé par votre par votre le
cas pratique
c'est un peu légitime qu'une personne
qui déjà propriétaire de la moitié
puisse un peu décider et sans avoir un
enfant qui veuille
ce qu'il détient une part se mettre en
travers de son chemin et faire échec à
une vente et si donc je pense que le cas
pratique évoqué n'est pas la grande
majorité des successions à régler et des
difficultés pour régler des successions
que nous avons et encore une fois sans
être je suis plutôt
je suis pas partisan ou défenseur de la
loi de chimie mais comme je constate
qu'elle est là pour aider la résolution
de nos succession anciennes il faut
quand même qu'on la défende et malgré
toutes ces
imperfections la règle de la majorité
est venue
infléchir la règle celle de l'unanimité
qui est impossible à bouger et si vous
permettez encore
le lundi diviseur qui est récalcitrant
et qui voudrait pas se voir
qu'il faudrait pas se voir la loi
imposée de celle du on va dire du plus
grand nombre
Naka acheté en fait si vous voulez parce
qu'il a un droit son droit d'indiviseur
est toujours là donc par rapport à un
tiers
si ce fait imposer par une décision de
justice ou disons une
l'application de la loi de la majorité
la vente à un tiers à l'indivision c'est
un petit peu parce qu'il n'a pas acheté
il a toujours un droit
de priorité simplement ne pouvant
peut-être pas concourir au paiement
parce qu'il n'est pas en mesure de le
faire il est il se voit il subit la
vente la vente un petit peu forcée si
vous voulez voilà je sais pas si j'ai
bien répondu
mais imaginez
une personne dans la situation évoquée
et qui vend à un étranger à l'indivision
que les coins divisé veulent faire jouer
leurs doigts de préemption dans le délai
imparti je dis bien moi je demande pas
un délai supplémentaire comment le faire
en plus vous notez l'instrumentaire vous
n'avez pas la répartition de la vente
entre coin divisés est-ce que oui on
peut je pense qu'on peut améliorer la
loi l'alchimie en prévoyant tout ça sans
pour autant avoir
cet éventail de textes différents en
évoquant ces voix une situation que vous
estimez être minoritaire mais ça pose
quelques problèmes dans certaines
familles et ça peut se répéter donc
voilà donc je pense qu'il y a des
propositions à faire pour améliorer le
dispositif
oui oui sans doute si je veux pas parler
à la place de mec je ne veux pas parler
à la place de mes coups confrères
monsieur sénateur Hurel effectivement
raison
encore une je comprends et je pense que
c'est un cas qui pourrait mais qui a pu
être rencontré puisqu'il l'évoque et qui
peut-être plus rare que l'immense
majorité des situations d'indivision
qui a voulu résoudre
le président la chimie enfin de la pub
président de notre
de notre
mais je pense que
je pense encore une fois que c'est sûr
que ce sont des contraintes mais vous
savez avant d'arriver à l'application de
la loi
on a quand même pas mal discuté entre
héritier ce sont des années qui se sont
qui se sont passés et c'est une
situation plutôt de de statu quo
parce que personne n'est d'accord qui
fait que une majorité décide de la vente
je sais que c'est pas parfait je peux
pas peut-être qu'il y a des
améliorations là-dessus à faire
je me permets après 10 ans tu ne payes
pas de droit apparemment il y a
objectivement intérêt pour découvrir
de ne pas liquider la succession puisque
je demande est-ce que c'est vrai après
10 ans Ben 10 ans après le décès les
coven diviseurs ne payent pas de droit
est-ce vrai ce qui fait que vous avez
objectivement intérêt à attendre 10 ans
et à ne pas liquider l'indivision cela
étant j'ajoute un point de vue
sociologique j'ai eu à dire dans une
émission sur le foncier agricole en
Guadeloupe récemment que c'est
l'indivision qui a sauvé un petit peu si
j'ose dire l'offensive guadeloupéen qui
est vendu très souvent
au milieu enfin mais au meilleur prix et
il y a beaucoup de demandes notamment de
russe de Suisse de mes collègues de la
métropole qui viennent acheter en
Guadeloupe
si les terres n'étaient pas un
indivision je peux vous dire un pan
entier du patrimoine foncier du pays se
répartit ailleurs et les collectivités
les autorités la Chambre des notaires
ils n'ont pas les moyens pour s'opposer
à la liberté des transactions c'est
pourquoi dans les demandes notamment
statutaires ou de différenciation du
droit nous demandons à avoir un droit de
regard sur le patrimoine foncier sur la
protection du patrimoine foncier comment
le faire dans une économie libérale
c'est un vrai sujet Comment permettre
une certaine liberté ou la liberté des
transactions du marché foncier mais en
même temps préserver ce qui a préservé
alors c'est vrai ça relève de l'identité
un peu l'équilibre un peu compliqué à
trouver pour autant moi je plaide pour
l'amélioration de la loi les chimie à
l'époque on a tenté de le faire mais bon
je n'ai pas à dire certains noms on n'a
pas pu le faire aujourd'hui probablement
il faut le faire et il y a plusieurs
types qui sont d'ailleurs prêts pour
améliorer le texte et pour qu'il soit
exécutable exécute trois et efficace et
efficient voilà
alors sur l'exonération si vous me
permettez sur le premier point de
Monsieur sur l'exonération
il est immédiat il faut pas attendre les
10 ans si vous voulez hein la loi a
prévu l'entrée en vigueur de
l'exonération pour 10 ans mais dès
aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'un partage
ou une succession qui s'ouvre et
avec une vent avec une licitation ou un
partage immédiat les les 2 50 du droit
de partage sont exonérés immédiatement
et ce jusqu'en 2028 d'accord donc on a
demandé la prorogation de cette dans à
la suite du colloque sur les problèmes
de division d'outre-mer nous avons
demandé la prolongation de cette de ce
système je voulais vous dire simplement
il bénéficie exclusivement à nos
compatriotes et à nos et aux concitoyens
parce que ils sont c'est eux qui sont en
indivision c'est quand ils partagent
entre eux la licitation vente entre les
héritiers donc quand ils partagent entre
eux c'est là qu'il bénéficie de
l'exonération de l'ennemi à l'instar de
l'accord et la Corse avait eu ça et on a
demandé à l'époque la Chambre des
notaires de la Martinique avait demandé
une application aussi donc ça ce droit
de partager exonéré ne bénéficiez pas au
tiers à l'indivision c'est pour les
étrangers à la famille il en ont pas
donc celui qui va acheter un bien d'une
situation d'indivision les chimie ou pas
avec la procédure latinie ou pas lui il
va payer ses taxes aux droits normal
dont la taxe la plus importante que vous
savez monsieur le sénateur revient au
département ou à la collectivité voilà
pour le deuxième point vous avez raison
enfin je peux pas aller contre vous
l'indivision a permis un statu quo c'est
certain le problème alors je peux pas
répondre aux problèmes qui sont plus
politiques puisque et puis là on on
s'écarte peut-être pour une part du
sujet si on parlait de des terres
agricoles parce que là par contre le
prix est réglementé mais vous avez
raison l'indivision crée le statu quo le
problème c'est que l'indivisaire est
piégé entre guillemets dans une
situation d'indivision et ne peut en
sortir avec la remise de son émolument
de son droit dans l'indivision et comme
vous connaissez l'adage et le droit
nécessaire c'est resté dans l'indivision
voilà c'est ce que je voulais rajouter
est-ce que Maître ponce et maître arrow
voudrait rajouter quelque chose
là-dessus ou ont-ils d'autres
informations nous communiquer
[Musique]
je crois que la Commission sur
l'indivision qui a eu lieu en janvier
beaucoup travaillé sur sur cela et que
les choses sont en cours pour améliorer
le système à mettre en place je
cherchais juste à comprendre ce que
monsieur le sénateur cherche à faire
est-ce qu'il cherchait à mettre un
nouveau droit de prendre sur en place
pour les coins du viseur
est-ce qu'un
nouveau droit de prendre soin devait
être mis ce qui souhaitait mettre un
nouveau droit de promotion
pour le pour les pour les minoritaires
oui exactement dans le délai
effectivement initial c'est ça si j'ai
bien compris victoire dans le délai
initial effectivement permettre aux
individus d'avoir un droit de prévention
de priorité en cas de licitation entre
entre héritiers c'est bien ça
semble-t-il
[Musique]
juste de l'autre côté notariat cela
alourdirait la loi le chimie
cela leur dirait la procédure de
rajouter un droit de préemption lorsque
une majorité est mise en place
pour faire face au cas de du conjoint
qui qui serait majoritaire et qui aurait
le droit de sa qualité de majoritaire je
reprends les propos de Monsieur de
mettre survie de mon frère qui disait
que il est tout à fait normal que dans
le cas d'une situation où déjà ils
peuvent le faire monsieur ils peuvent le
faire déjà aujourd'hui c'est le texte
des coin divisés 2 3 coins diviseurs qui
se coalisent pour acheter sont réputés
achetés ensemble simplement ils doivent
l'exercer bon simplement là dans la loi
des chimie je suis pas sûr qu'il soit
éligible et c'est de l'étendre à toute
vente sous régime les timide de pouvoir
le faire
d'étudier voir et même chose d'ailleurs
pour la répartition du produit de la
vente c'est pas dans le c'est des
difficultés pratiques qu'il faut à mon
sens lever
et puisque vous en êtes là je me permets
présidents sur le prix des terres
agricoles et sur le prix de location le
prix de location
depuis la dur qui a
supprimé l'ordonnance de 45 nous sommes
en économie libre en économie libérale
il n'y a pas de fixation de prix sauf à
l'époque où le pain aujourd'hui ça a
disparu pour chez nous
les énergies le carburant le pétrole et
autres gaz
c'était les cantines scolaires
maintenant c'est les maires qui fixent
il reste les bords
il reste les bourreaux il reste le bail
rural ou le bail à long terme c'est le
préfet
les textes sont récemment si le préfet
qui part arrêter dit que nectar de
banane c'est tant de banane c'est une
quantité de Madame multipliée par un
index et qui donne le prix
et la valorisation de l'hectare ou du
loyer agricole personne ne respecte ça
je sais même pas d'ailleurs si les prix
fait pour toujours ses arrêtés pour un
hectare de Cannes un hectare à maréchal
un hectare en élevage etc il y a des
index et des pondérations qui permettent
de prendre des arrêtés et qui fixent
mais je peux vous dire personne ne
respecte cela lorsqu'il y a des
transactions sur un hectare de terre
agricole et peut-être quand la SAFER
fait jouer son doigt préemption là là ça
va faire un pose un prix et d'ailleurs
faudrait permettre à la SAFER comme on
l'a vu dans une autre audition de le
faire un peu par partie par des membres
sans pouvoir acheter le local parce que
même les affaires n'ont pas les moyens
pour acheter ces terres-là mais personne
ne vend au prix fixé par les arrêter
préfectoraux c'est en dessous de table
depuis la loi Sapin sapin 2 qui dit que
vous ne pouvez plus payer plus de 1000
euros c'était 3000 € en liquide
maintenant c'est 1000 € avant c'était
des dessous de table en vous disant
m'intéresse 10000 13000 15000 euh
euro hectare et 20 c'était déjà un prix
extraordinaire non c'est 50000 euros ou
c'est 60 000 euros tu me donnes le reste
en dessous de table je parle là cache
avec vous et bien aujourd'hui c'est pas
possible la banque vous dit mais c'est
pourquoi faire là avec vos 20000 ou
30000 euros là il y a un vrai sujet sur
le blocage qu'est-ce qui se passe donc
ce sont ceux et celles qui peuvent payer
qui achètent les terres donc il y a une
concentration qui se fait et des
inégalités qui soient creuses parce que
là c'est un peu payé d'autre part donc
je dis ça là je déborde un peu de
l'audition mais il est certain que ce
mécanisme là est à l'oeuvre dans les
îles et pas simplement Walker dans les
îles c'est un phénomène insulaire qu'on
a pas véritablement étudier
alors pour j'interviens ensuite suite à
cette
information
dans les mots par contre alors que ça
soit pour juste recentrer le
effectivement il y a les il y a le prix
du bail c'était la location de la terre
et le prix des terres lors d'une vente
le pour le prix des baux alors pour les
beaux que nous faisons mais monsieur
c'est effectivement nous en faisons pas
beaucoup mais des beaux ruraux nous
sommes obligés et nous respectons et les
gens connaissent le tarif alors
effectivement vous avez raison ce sont
des arrêtés préfectoraux qui sont
anciens et qui n'ont jamais alors le
dernier pour chez nous et de 2011 et il
n'a pas il n'a pas été modifié
en termes de les montants les montants
du coût des denrées qui sont pris et les
volumes de denrées puisqu'il y a donc
vous comme vous le disiez il y a deux
facteurs il y a un volume de denrées et
le coût de la denrée qui fixe le montant
du loyer alors avec des pondérations
comme vous le rappeliez pour des biens
qui sont dans des dans des secteurs qui
sont
soit alimenté en eau soit qui sont sur
des des zones plus sèches ou plus ou
plus
pluvieuse et donc nous devons respecter
ces tarifs et les gens les connaissent
donc j'ouvre un une parenthèse peut-être
que certains biens ne sont pas mis en
location parce que les loyers sont pas
assez importants mais je ne pense pas on
a un système en tout cas qui qui existe
souvent on a des systèmes qu'on ne met
pas assez en œuvre mais il y a un
système qui existe et qui est dans les
mains de la SAFER qui est la mise en
œuvre du bail forcée pour les terres qui
sont
en friche et non cultivées et puis après
il y a le prix des terres agricoles et
là où vous aviez raison donc il y a des
prix de terre qui sont peut-être
considérés comme pas suffisant et je ne
sais pas comment ça se règle mais quand
on fait un prix de terres agricole on
est obligé non seulement de passer par
les fourches codes de la SAFER qui
contrôle pour l'installation des jeunes
agriculteurs etc et puis pour qu'il y
ait pas d'inflation sur le prix des
terres agricoles et nous sommes dans
l'ordre de 5 à 7000 euros donc une
moyenne de 6000 euros lecteur à la
Martinique pour ceux qui nous concerne
et effectivement si le prix est trop
élevé la sorcière Prée pour rétablir le
prix et fait une contre-proposition de
prix voilà effectivement
quand il y a des bâtiments qui sont mis
en garagricole qui a mis en location sur
la terre qui est qui bâillait il y a un
supplément du loyer qui peut être donné
pour le
bâti de même que quand il y a une vente
il y a le prix des agricoles elle-même
nu et il y a le prix du bâti donc il
peut se décortiquer pour que la SAFER
apprécie et si elle a droit à intervenir
ou pas voilà
écoutez maître en vous remerci
infiniment pour toutes ces informations
il est certain que l'on aurait pu
prolonger
nos questions mais vous avez donc on
vous a adressé un questionnaire sur
lequel on aimerait peut-être que vous
nous fassiez les contributions écrites
un particulier sur le fond comme le font
agricole sur le modèle du fonds de
commerce comme à poser la question de
mon collègue tany Mohamed Souali et les
propositions que vous pourriez nous
faire par écrit bon nous avons une autre
audition suite vous donc on va devoir
conclure
ce que cet entretien on vous remercie
infiniment quand même de tout ce que
vous avez pu nous donner et on vous
remercie par avance de toutes les
contributions écrites que vous pourrez
nous communiquer par écrit bien
évidemment et les propositions peut-être
que vous pourriez les suggestions que
vous pourriez nous faire merci beaucoup
je repasse la parole à notre président
mais pas grand chose d'autre à rajouter
si ce n'est de vous souhaiter une bonne
fin de journée pour certains de soirées
pour d'autres si j'ai bien compris merci
vraiment de de vos éclairages et vos
contributions merci à très bientôt au
revoir
merci au revoir